hi my name is maria eldeeb i was born in
egypt worked on a farm until third grade
and then we came i came with my family
to the usa and i worked we could i
continued working and also going to
school since we had to but working full
time made
didn't make school go i was mostly
sleeping and i wasn't doing well at all
and that continued this that same exact
way till 8th grade and my family was
also in the middle going back and forth
between egypt and here and nobody had
decided exactly what we're doing
but then when high school started two
weeks in my house burned and i was like
that's it for school you know there's
there's no way it's gonna work out
anymore but after a year and a half of
being homeless and on a shelter my
family was able to move into somewhere
stable and life was getting a little
stable so i was willing to give high
school another shot and let's see you
know if i could really if school would
actually work out for me thank god i
found khan academy and they had
everything that i needed because i
needed pre-pre algebra to actually start
my way and actually be able to learn at
an equal level so they had it all for me
you know they had pre-algebra and then
pre and then they had algebra and then
they they had the whole path just set up
right there for you where i didn't even
have to organize it or find someone help
me organize or figure out what i would
do and
i went down through every video and as i
learned and i learned and things were
getting easier and the pace was what i
wanted
it motivated me a lot that i felt like i
could actually learn and i was learning
and getting happier and things were
working out you know and i continued
that same way and that even drove in a
love for math for me and after finishing
every video that was there i finished
high school in that year and a half i
graduated in 11th grade after finishing
11th grade and
i basically i we i went to queen's
college and
i i knew i could learn math so i
continued learning math
and khan academy was still there for me
they had calculus and they had they
continued to statistics and probability
and every class that i
needed to continue to get my to do well
in math and i was able to finish in my
applied math degree in two and a half
years and now i'm doing my second
bachelor's here at columbia university
after transferring here